Spirituális alapok, a spirituális
vezetés. Írta Rick Bidenbow. Majd ezt
mondta Mózes az Úrnak: Nézd, te azt
mondod nekem, hogy vezessem ezt a népet,
de nem adtad tudtomra, kit küldesz
velem. Pedig azt mondtad, név szerint
ismerlek téged, és elnyerted jó
indulatomat. Ha valóban elnyertem jó
indulatodat, ismertesd meg velem a te
utadat, hogy megismerjelek téged, és
hogy elnyerjem jó indulatodat. Nézd, ez
a nép mégis csak a te néped. Az Úr így
felelt: Megnyugtat téged, ha az orcán
megy veletek. Mózes második könyve 33.
fejezet 12-től 14. versig. Nehéz a
vezetést önmagában meghatározni, és a
spirituális vezetés témája még
bonyolultabb. Valójában nem minden
vezetés spirituális. Hiszünk abban, hogy
minden vezetést valamilyen lelkület,
angolul spirit irányít és szolgál. A
kérdés csak az, hogy milyen az a
lelkület. Adolf Hitler például hatékony
vezető volt, vízióval, erőforrásokkal és
végrehajtó hatalommal. De őt és vezetői
csapatát a gyűlölet, a fanatizmus és a
manipuláció gonosz lelkületei
vezérelték.
Minden vezető azt a lelkületet, lelket
szolgálja, amelyik irányítja őt. Az
üzleti életben számos olyan vezető van,
akit a kabzsiság, önérvényesítés és
uralkodás lelke vezérel. Ha nem a
megfelelő lélek irányítja őket, akkor az
üzleti vezetők számára a munka vagy a
profit kerülhet az első helyre. Az Isten
lelke által vezérelt üzleti vezetők is
elismerik a munka és profit
szükségességét,
de nem ezeket tekintik a
legfontosabbnak. Ha Isten lelke hiányzik
egy vezető életéből, az nem jelent
spirituálisan semleges állapotot, hanem
ehelyett tökéletes otthont nyújt más
szellemek számára. Egyszerűen
fogalmazva, ha nem Isten lelke tölt be
és vezet minket, akkor valamilyen más
lélek vagy szellem fog vezetni és
betölteni. Az a szellem pedig a saját
céljai felé fog irányítani, nem pedig
Isten szándéka felé. Isten teremtett
minket. Ő tökéletesen szeret, és a
legjobbat akarja nekünk. A lelke által
rajtunk keresztül is cselekszik mindenki
javára és fejlődésére.
Az ő terve a legjobb terv, és a lelke
átalakít minket, hogy valóban szeretni
tudjuk az embereket, és jobban törődjünk
velük, mint magunkkal. Ezt nem tudjuk
megtenni, ha Isten nem formál át minket,
és nem alakulhatunk át az ő bennünk élő
lelke nélkül. Keressétek először Isten
országát és az ő igazságát, és
mindezeket megkapjátok.
Máté evangéliuma hatodik fejezet 33.
vers. A Badenbow Companies
igazgatótanácsa és vezetői csapata
fokozatosan átengedte az Úrnak az
irányítást az üzleti vállalkozás felett.
Most már tudjuk, hogy a mi
vállalkozásunk az ő szolgálata. Ennek
megfelelően az igazgatótanácsunk
meghatározta a küldetésünket.
Isten és az ő királyságának
kinyilatkoztatása az üzleti életben
végzett munkánk által.
Ahhoz, hogy ez a királysággal
kapcsolatos küldetés megvalósuljon,
mindenekelőtt vezetőinknek Isten
lelkével kell betelniük, és az ő
vezetésével kell dolgozniuk.
Fogadd el Isten akaratát. Ő alapozta meg
a tekintélyedet.
A rettenthetetlen című lenyűgöző filmben
a főszereplő William Well a való
életében és halálában Skóciát vezette a
függetlenségéért Angliával vívott
küzdelemben. Elismert vezető volt, és
hivatalosan is lovaggá ütötték. Amikor
egy másik szereplő a filmben
megjegyezte: "Megkaptad a Sir Wallest
címet?" Ő így válaszolt: "Nem kaptam
semmit. Isten teszi az embereket azzá,
amik." Ámen. Minden lélek
engedelmeskedjék a felettes hatalmaknak,
mert nincs hatalom mástól, mint
Istentől. Ami hatalom pedig van,
Istentől rendeltetett.
Aki tehát nem engedelmeskedik a
hatalomnak, az Isten rendelkezésével
fordul szembe. Akik pedig szembe
fordulnak vele, azok maguknak
köszönhetik ítéletüket. Rómaiakhoz írt
levél 13. fejezet első második vers. Ha
megerősítették a hatalmadat az emberek,
és megbíztak egy csapat vezetésével,
valójában semmit sem kaptál. Isten
rendelte el a hatalmadat, hiszen nincs
hatalom csak Isten által. Az igazi
alázat az, hogy elfogadod Isten
akaratát. Érts egyet vele, fogadd el az
ő kinevezését. Légy lovag. Ugyanakkor
nem helyes hatalmat szerezni a személyes
haszonszerzés érdekében. A hatalom nem a
vezetőjavát szolgálja, hanem azokét,
akiket vezet. Míg egyesek a vezetést
hatalomként látják, az igazi vezetők
felelősségként tekintenek rá. Isten nem
engedi, hogy az önző haszonszerzés által
vezérelt hatalom fennmadjon. Ezért dönts
úgy, hogy elfogadod Isten akaratát, és
engedelmeskedj neki, hogy azok az
emberek, akiket vezetsz, Isten szándéka
szerint kiteljesedhessenek.
Segítsd őket, hogy a legjobbak legyenek,
és vezesd őket nagy eredmények felé. Ez
a helyes lelkülete Isten spirituális
vezetőinek.
Kérd Istent, hogy vezessen, meg fogja
tenni. Mózes arra kérte az Urat, hogy
tanítsa meg őt az ő útjaira.
rendszeresen találkozott vele, hogy
irányítást kérjen a nép számára. Mivel
ez a vállalkozás Istené volt, Mózesnek
meg kellett állnia, és meg kellett
kérdeznie: Merre menjünk, Uram?
Vezetőként, erős akaratú emberként nem
szeretünk megállni és útbaigazítást
kérni, de a spirituális vezető alázatos.
Hát állj meg és kérdezd meg. A
spirituális vezetők megértik, hogy ez
Isten királysága. Hogyan lehetnénk
vezetők az ő királyságában, ha nem
töltünk a királlyal időt? Ha nem
beszélgetsz rendszeresen a királlyal,
valószínűleg a saját királyságodat
építed.
Egy spirituális vezetőnek rendszeresen
időt kell szánnia arra, hogy megpihenjen
Isten jelenlétében és hallgassa őt. A
Biblia azt mondja, hogy Jézust mindenhol
tömegvette körül. Az emberek kérdésekkel
fordultak hozzá, miközben a tanítványait
is vezette. Mégis Jézus szakított időt
arra, hogy felmenjen a hegyre és időt
töltsön az Atyával. Máté evangéliuma 14.
fejezet 23. vers. Márk evangéliuma első
fejezet 35. vers. Lukács evangéliuma 5.
fejezet 16. vers és hatod. 12. vers.
Hogyan tudta volna Atya ügyét
képviselni, ha nem töltött volna vele
időt? Neked mikor a legalkalmasabb a nap
folyamán, hogy leülj Istennel és
meghallgasd?
Isten vezetőének minden nap olvasniuk és
tanulmányozniuk kell az ő igéjét, és
időt kell tölteniük vele. Elköteleződni
fontos emellett még akkor is, amikor
elfoglaltabb időszakokon megyünk
keresztül, és nehéz megállnunk, hogy
meghallgassuk őt. Emellett hívnunk is
kell, kérnünk kell a jelenlétét, hogy
velünk legyen egész nap. Istennel együtt
kell haladnunk, az ő lelkének kell
vezetnie minket. Tedd a szokásoddá, hogy
Istennel beszélgetsz a nap folyamán. Az
Úr pedig színről színre beszélt
Mózessel, ahogy az egyik ember beszél a
másikkal. Mózes második könyve 33.
fejezet 11. vers. Isten az emberekért ad
nekünk hatalmat, nem pedig az emberek
fölött, hogy ő hozzávezethessük őket az
ő magasabb célja érdekében. Törődnünk
kell velük és gondoskodnunk kell róluk,
hiszen így fogjuk megszeretni őket. Nem
a saját hasznunkért, vagy azért, amit a
munkájukkal tehetnek értünk, hanem hogy
megismerjék általunk Isten feltétel
nélküli szeretetét. Ne csak úgy
tegyetek, mintha szeretnétek másokat.
Tényleg szeressétek őket. Utáljátok, ami
rossz, ragaszkodjatok ahhoz, ami jó.
Szeressétek egymást őszinte szeretettel,
és örömmel adjátok meg egymásnak a
tiszteletet. Rómaiakhoz írt levél 12.
fejezet 9. vers. Ez nem arról szól, hogy
megmentünk embereket, csak Isten menthet
meg. A mi feladatunk, hogy valóban
szeressük az embereket hiteles,
átlátható kapcsolatokban.
Hogyan vezethetnénk jól az embereket, ha
nem szeretjük őket igazán?
Isten által felkent. A legtöbb vezető
időnként alkalmatlannak érzi magát egy
helyzetre, vagy akár egy időszakra is.
De az Isten felken minket, az ő lelke
által felkészít, és ezzel erőt ad, hogy
teljesítsük, amit megkövetel vezetői
küldetésünk. Isten ereje az ő lelke
által úgy nyilvánul meg bennünk, mint
tudás, bölcsesség, tisztánlátás,
készség, jó indulat és vízió, hogy olyan
dolgokat lássunk és tegyünk, amik
természet feletti módon túlmutatnak a
normális képességeinken.
Isten felkészít azzal, hogy felkeni a
lelkével a vezetőit. Akkor ezt mondta az
Úr: "Rajta kend föl királyá, mert ő az!"
Sámuel pedig fogta az olajos szarút, és
testvérei körében fölkente őt. Akkor az
Úr lelke szállt Dávidra, és attól kezdve
vele is maradt. Sámuel első könyve 16.
fejezet 12-13. vers. A latin eredetű
felkenés szó folyamatos cselekvést fejez
ki. Isten kenete folyamatos és egyre
növekvő, ahogy keressük őt. Kérj meg
másokat is, hogy vezessenek veled
együtt. Nem tudsz, és nem is szabad
egyedül vezetned. A vezető
elszigeteltsége nem jó dolog.
Meghiúsulnak a tervek, ha nincs
tanácskozás, de megvalósulnak, ha van
sok tanácsadó. Példabeszédek könyve 15.
fejezet 22. vers. Apám és én együtt
hoztuk létre a Been Bow Holmes
vállalatot, és bár tudtuk, hogy
kiegészítjük egymást, valakinek vezetnie
kellett. Alázatos természete és
személyisége miatt apám őszintén hitt
abban, hogy a lakásépítő cégünk számára
megfelelő az általam megálmodott
jövőkép, és én vagyok az alkalmas
személy annak vezetésére. Azt is
javasolta, hogy tiszteljük meg Istent a
partnerséggel, és én egyetértettem vele.
Az üzlet jól ment, de nem vezettem
igazán jól az embereket. Nagy volt a
fluktuáció, és hogy őszinte legyek,
középszerű vállalatként működtünk. Holly
vezette az adományozásunkat. De Isten
többet akart, és én tudtam ezt.
Elkezdtem keresni az Urat, hogy
megtudjam, mit vár el tőlem vezetőként.
Ahogy kerestem az Urat, kezdtem őt
igazán meghallani a vezetésemmel
kapcsolatban. Eljött hozzám, és azt
mondta, válasszak ki néhány megbízható
menedzsert, és alakítsunk vezetői
csapatot. Elkezdtük együtt keresni őt,
és felépíteni egy menedzsment csapatot,
amelyet mi fogunk vezetni. Aztán
elmondta nekem még ezeket is. Meg akarta
védeni a vállalatot tőlem, mert az
abszolút hatalom teljesen megront. Meg
akart védeni engem önmagamtól, majdnem
megölt az egyedüli vezetésterhe.
Számadással tartoztam ennek a csapatnak.
Nem demokráciát kellett megvalósítanunk.
Nem adtam fel, vagy hagytam el a
felelősségemet szenior vezetőként. Csak
Isten mentheti fel a vezetőit azokból a
hatáskörökből, amelyeket rájuk bízott.
Azonban együtt fogunk vezetni.
Megszületett az első vezetői csapatunk,
a mai igazgatótanács. Rick, Ron és
Holly, valamint Megan, Bob, Carry, John
és Charlie. Minden döntést közösen
hoztunk meg, és ahogy egyre jobban
megtanultuk, hogyan kérdezzük az Urat,
úgy váltak egyre jobbá a döntéseink.
Megtanultuk igazán szeretni a másikat és
megbízni egymásban, valamint hagyni,
hogy az Úr mindannyiunkhoz szóljon
mindegyikünkön keresztül. Ezután ho az
Úr hozzánk sok jelenlegi vezetőnket, és
valóban létrehozott egy
menedzsmentcsapatot, amely a mi
vezetésünk alatt irányítja az ő
vállalatát. Egy magot ültettünk el,
amely egy csodálatos együttműködő
csapatmunkát eredményező kultúrává nőtte
ki magát. És én nem haltam meg, hanem
igazán elkezdtem élni. Az ellenség
szereti megtámadni az elszigetelt
vezetőket. ők könnyen
összezaabarodhatnak és célpontokká
válhatnak, mint ahogy Dávid király is
elszigetelődött és a bűn prédájává vált.
Sámuel második könyve 11. fejezet
elsőtől az ötödik versig. Csapatoknak
kell vezetniük az Isten ügyeit. Ezeknek
a csapatoknak alá kell rendelniük
magukat mind az Istennek, mind a csapat
vezetőjének. Azonban a vezető
felelősséggel tartozik a csapatáért, és
önmagánál is jobban kell szeretnie őket.
Így néz ki a kapcsolatuk. Minden vezető
Istennek van alárendelve, a felső
vezetőt is beleértve. Minden vezető
alárendelt a felettes vezetője Istentől
kapott tekintélyének.
Minden vezető elszámolással tartozik a
többieknek. A szenior vezető felelőssége
a legnagyobb a többiek felé. A
döntéshozatal nagy együttműködésen
alapul és átlátható. A szenior vezetőjé
a végső döntésga, de ritkán használja
ezt. Az ötletek azonnal közösségi
tulajdonná válnak, és elvész annak a
jelentősége, hogy ki volt az ötletgazda.
Egy egészséges csapat gyümölcsei
lehetnek például a szeretet uralkodik,
valódi, őszinte és átlátható kapcsolatok
jellemzik, és az együttlétet mindenki
élvezi. Isten áldása van a csapat
egységén, még akkor is, ha egészséges
nézeteltéseik is vannak. Természetes az
elszámoltathatóság a tetteinkért,
szavainkért és a munkánk eredményeiért.
Mindenki nyitott erre és kimméletesen,
de rendszeresen gyakorolja ezt a
többiekkel, beleértve a csapat legfőbb
vezetőjét is. Nincs félelem a
retorzióktól, és mindannyian Istent
halljuk egymás által. Mindenki nyitott
az új ötletekre. Az együttműködés azt
jelenti, hogy jól kijövünk egymással, és
ez jó dolog. Az együttalkotás azt
jelenti, hogy közösen dolgozunk, és ez
nagyszerű. Isten megáldja az
együttműködést és megsokszorozza az
eredményeket. Lehetnek heves viták, de
mindenki hiszi, hogy az én ötletem sosem
annyira jó, mint a mi közös ötletünk.
Senki sincs elszigetelve a csapattól,
úgy, hogy külön dolgozik rendszeres napi
kapcsolat nélkül, sebezhetővé válva az
ellenség támadásaival szemben. Egy
csapat akkor egészséges, ha a tagjai
egészségesek. Az emberek elkötelezettek,
szeretve érzik magukat, kihívások elé
állítják őket, és felelősséggel
tartoznak. Ilyen egy gyümölcsöző csapat.
Engedelmeskedj Istennek, teljesen
rendeld alá magad. Ez vetett véget Saul
királyságának Izraelben. Pedig az ő
felkenésével kezdődött minden. Sámuel
első könyve 10. fejezet első verse
alapján. Ekkor fogta Sámuel az olajos
korsót, öntött belőle Saul fejére,
megcsókolta, és ezt mondta: Ezennel
fölkent téged az Úr öröksége
fejedelmévé.
Ezt olvashatjuk néhány verssel később.
És amikor Saul megfordult, hogy
eltávozzék Sámueltől, Isten
megváltoztatta a szívét, és
beteljesedtek rajta mindezek a jelek
azon a napon, akkor megszállta az Isten
lelke. De idővel Saul feladta az
engedelmességet, és inkább követte a
saját akaratát.
pedig az Úr utasításai, ahogyan az
Sámuel első könyvének 15. fejezetében a
harmadik versben olvasható, teljesen
egyértelműek voltak. Most menj, támadd
meg az amalekitákat, és teljesen
pusztítsd el mindazt, ami az övék. Ne
kiméj meg semmit, öld meg a férfiakat és
nőket, gyermekeket és csecsemőket,
szarvasmarhákat, juhokat, tevéket és
szamarakat. Saul azonban kifogásokat
keresett, más célokra hivatkozott, hogy
megváltoztassa Isten tökéletesen világos
utasításait. A katonák megkímélték a
juhok és marhák legjavát, hogy az Úrnak,
a te Istenednek áldozzák fel őket, de a
többit teljesen elpusztítottuk. Akkor
ezt mondta Sámuel: Talán ugyanúgy
tetszik az Úrnak az égő és a véres
áldozat, mint az engedelmesség az Úr
szava iránt. Bizony többet ér az
engedelmesség az áldozatnál és a
szófogadás a kosok kövérjénél. Olyan az
engedetlenség, mint a varázslás vétke,
és az ellenszegülés, mint a
bálványimádás.
Te megvetetted az Úr igéjét, ő pedig
elvetett téged, és nem leszel király.
Sámuel első könyve 15. fejezet 22.-23.
vers. A spirituális vezetés megköveteli,
hogy kérjünk Istentől útmutatást, és ha
meghalljuk, engedelmeskedjünk neki. Csak
akkor teljesül a vezetői szövetségünk
Istennel, ha engedelmeskedünk.
Isten vezetőinek folyamatosan teljes
mértékben alá kell vetniük magukat az ő
tekintélyének. Különben nem bízza rájuk
az ő népét. Ez gyakran nem annyira Isten
akaratának megértésén múlik. Sokkal
inkább azon, hogy egyszerűen
engedelmeskedünk-e, ha már tudjuk, mi
az. Isten világosan szólt Saulhoz, de ő
nem követte az utasításait.
Mózes hasonló történetet élt át. Mózes
negyedik könyve 20. fejezete szerint.
Isten mindkét esetben leváltotta őket a
nép vezetői posztjáról.
Ahogyan a vezetőknek alá kell vetniük
magukat Isten tekintélyének, úgy
azoknak, akiket vezetünk, a mi
tekintélyünknek kell alávetniük magukat.
Szeretjük őket, gondoskodunk róluk, de
kevés dolog szakít szét egy csapatot
olyan gyorsan, mint egy lázadó szellem,
amely nem hajlandó alávetni magát a
vezetőjének. Jelen lehet sok
szenvedélyes és különféle vélemény, de
végül mindenkinek be kell állni a
tekintélyi mögé. Azokat a csapattagokat,
akik aláássák a tekintélyt, azonnal és
határozottan kezelni kell. Ez a vezetői
felelősségünk része. Ha ez elmarad, az
eredmény széthúzás lesz, amit Isten nem
áld meg. Az ő áldása egy egységes
csapaton van, amely az ő tekintély és az
általa kijelölt vezető tekintély alatt
áll. Minden lélek engedelmeskedjék a
felettes hatalmaknak, mert nincs hatalom
mástól, mint Istentől. Ami hatalom pedig
van, Istentől rendeltetett. Aki tehát
nem engedelmeskedik a hatalomnak, az
Isten rendelkezésével fordul szembe.
Akik pedig szembe fordulnak vele, azok
magukra köszönhetik ítéletüket. Mert nem
a jó cselekedet miatt kell félni az
előjáróktól, hanem a rossz miatt. Azt
akarod, hogy ne kelljen félned a
hatalomtól? Tedd a jót, és dicséretet
kapsz tőle, mert Isten szolgálja ő neked
a jó elősegítésére.
Ha azonban a rosszat teszed, akkor félj,
mert nem ok nélkül viseli a kardot,
hiszen ő Isten szolgája, aki az ő
haragját hajtja végre azon, aki a
rosszat teszi. Ezért tehát
engedelmeskedni kell nemcsak a harag
miatt, hanem a lelki ismeret miatt is.
Rómaiakhoz írt levél 13. fejezet elsőtől
ötödik versig.
Szellemi ellenállás.
Mivel minden vezetés spirituális
jellegű, ezért amikor a vezetők Isten
szándékát keresik, az ellenség
ellenállásával találkozhatnak.
Az ellenség a füledbe suttoghat. Nem
vagy elég spirituális ember, nem tudod
megcsinálni. Nem vagy elég jó. A
munkahely nem Isten vagy a hite. Az
emberek, akiket vezetsz, őrültnek fognak
tartani. Mert mi nem test és vér ellen
harcolunk, hanem erők és hatalmak ellen,
a sötétség világának urai és a gonoszság
lelkei ellen, amelyek a mennyei
magasságban vannak. Efezusiaknak írt
levél, hatodik fejezet 12. vers. Ezek az
ellenség hazugságai. Az ellenség
szembeszegül a spirituális vezetéseddel,
de Isten rendelt vezetőnek, és ő vezetni
fog téged, a pártfogód lesz, ha őt
keresed, ha őszintén hitelesen és
szeretettel vezeted a csapatod, szem
előtt tartva az érdekeit. Igaz beszéd
ez, ha valaki püspökségre törekszik,
szép feladatra vágyik. Timóteushoz írt
első levél, harmadik fejezet, első vers.